I'm going to do a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little
bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit
of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of
a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a
little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little
bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit
of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of
a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a
little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little
Little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit
of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit
were a suit jacket, and made a habit of replacing sleep with coffee.
I had given this company a piece of my soul, only to watch my boss give his daughter the
position I had dedicated all these years working towards.
I wanted to scream in his skull, I wanted to cry like a child, but I couldn't.
I had been completely hollow for years, but now I was at my lowest low, nothing more to
strive for, nothing more to work for, nothing more to live for.
I wandered the night in a daze of utter aimlessness, yet, after sinking into the dark, I soon found
myself bathed in light.
It was a woman whose opulent beauty contrasted my disheveled despair.
Why was it then that I had caught her attention?
Not of disgust or pity, but I was instead called to the front of the line in a queue
of some very important looking people.
Without a word, her eyes gave an invitation, and her smile brought me both comfort of her
presence and the courage to follow.
Before I knew it, I was tailing her like a child into a building I had no business being
in, yet one she had total command of.
Every respectable patron and worker there from the highest walks of life called her Queen,
and the nature of that level of respect also made her Queen to me.
She had said she had seen a familiar pain in me and spoke to me about an offer.
Not a new job, but a new lifestyle.
She had brought me to the VIP section of the building and had finally dawned on me, a fetish
club for the rich and powerful.
My work didn't even allow me time for dating, much less anything here.
My curiosity and fear were at odds, yet Queen was understanding and familiar with my flavor
of reluctance.
She believed we were kindred spirits, though I couldn't see it.
In display of influence, she contacted my work, securing me a paid leave in order to
stay in Wonderland with complete access to all of its faculties for a week, free of
charge.
At the end of my stay, I would have to give my answer to join her in this wild new life,
a return to mediocrity.
To say I enjoyed my stay was an understatement.
I was finally tasting what life's joys can offer.
After the hotel amenities, spa, bars, and 5 star buffet, my curiosity eventually turned
to the VIP lounge.
It was there where I found myself.
It was there where I found my answer.
The pleasure I had never even knew I desired.
The pain I had no idea I needed.
This is what I deserved.
I found it all here.
My body was subjected to sensations and punishments my deepest imagination could never conjure.
That was, until they had me dishing it out as well.
After getting just a taste of this life, I knew there was no way I could turn down Queen's
offer.
I was now bound to this place.
In my service to Wonderland, I had been transformed.
In bondage, I found my freedom.
Through pain, I knew pleasure.
Through submission, I had found my power.
Through domination, I had found my peace.
I became a premier worker whose services were demanded by the highest paying clients from
across the world.
Top execs, actors, even politicians would line up to get their fill of welts and rope
burn.
I had seen more money in the first month than I'd ever seen in a year of office work.
My newfound command over the sins of the flesh gained me respect of peers as well as Queen
herself.
We had grown close, a bit more than professionally.
Despite this, even I had no idea what was to come.
She never wanted us to worry, so she never told anyone of her condition.
And it struck her hearts like a bolt of lightning when the time came.
When she passed, the city itself seemed to stand still in respect.
She had left behind a golden legacy as a saint of whips and gags, a woman who allowed those
scorned by the pursuit of happiness to regain their sense of passion and power.
She saw that need in me as well as my talent for it, and so did the others.
So when she willed her entire empire to me, there were no objections.
Thanks to her, I have attained a sense of power and family that I could have never imagined.
I will make sure that Wonderland will always be a safe haven for the rejected and the hopeless.
So if you feel trapped, finding yourself in a life of all pain and no pleasure, why not
step by a little while?
I can help you find both.
Don't be nervous, sweetie.
I know it's a big thing wanting to enter Wonderland.
It's important to have your consent, though, because once you enter, you might realize
you don't want to come back out of this little rabbit hole.
So, what will it be?
I don't know.
Mmm, good choice.
You've pleased me already and we're just getting started.
Why don't I tell you a little bit more about me then?
Hello.
Hi there.
Hello, sweetheart.
My name is Evie Cottonbum.
I'm your mistress and the madam of Wonderland.
Did you enjoy the girl so far?
I bet you enjoyed Emmy's debut.
Isn't she just the cutest?
Hope she didn't put too much of a spell on you.
Okay, well, now you do well to behave and listen.
We've got a bit to go through, so I'll just move right along.
However, first things first, we're going to practice some obedience.
So, I'm going to have you try something for me.
Can you say ah?
Ah, say ah.
Or type A's in the chat.
Good job.
I'm so proud of you.
Okay, so hold on.
Let me just come and set up my desk.
Just a second.
I'm sorry, my people need me.
Don't worry about my lack of head.
I still give it good.
Don't worry about it.
Okay, just don't.
So, yeah, I know my desk is messy.
I'll clean it off later.
As mentioned, my name is Sheeby,
but you must refer to me as Madam or Miss Sheeby, if you like.
Close confidants, call me Sheepsters.
My surname may sound silly to you,
but it's a known fact in my family that we have buns of steel.
My last name just showcases that.
I was born on September 28th, which just happens to be Bunny Day.
My parents just seemed to have really gotten the timing right, I suppose.
I am pretty tall in my family at 168 centimeters.
That's a 5'6 in America, if you didn't know.
I'm a lap and polla, otherwise known as a bunny girl.
You see, I have a lovely set of floppy ears in this picture right there.
I can also DJ, like, I'm just kidding.
I also have a very nice cotton tail.
I have the many characteristics of a rabbit, like my stamina, for example.
I'm also very good at jumping and have quite the vertical.
My family is mad at me, though, because I didn't pick up basketball,
like a distant relative of mine.
Everybody get up, it's time to slam-
Okay.
So, my age.
That's really quite rude of you to wonder.
And although I might have some motherly qualities,
I'm not old enough to be your mother.
As you saw in my little introductory video,
I am now Queen of Wonderland,
but I retired that title out of respect for the previous owner, Rest in Peace Queen.
I'll go into more of what my hotel offers in the 2.0.
In human languages, I only fluently know English,
but pleasure doesn't really need words, does it?
I'm also fluent in bun-speak,
but my accent and pitch, it really only comes out if I'm excited.
It sounds a bit like your animalese,
but I can use it in English as well, so normally it sounds like this.
But if I get really excited when I'm talking to you guys,
and this is very rare, this is what I sound like.
Okay.
So, let's look at my likes in this likes,
and a little bit of trivia about me.
Okay.
So, first of my likes, I really do enjoy a wide range of music genres,
from Grunge all the way to rap.
I can't sing well, but I try my best, and I just try to have fun with it.
Huge fan of really any sort of techno with bass and thump,
you can really feel anything that makes me move, besides country.
The only good songs to come from country are Ram Ranch,
and Save a Horse, Ride a Cowboy.
I'm not the pickiest eater, but I do have my favorites.
I love, love, love seafood.
I'm a woman of opulent taste, lobster.
There's probably no seafood dish I wouldn't try.
My mother also always prided in how well I ate my veggies as a wee rabbit.
I even like Brussels sprouts.
I love pho and Spanish food as well.
And I have a few junky comfort foods, like Uncrustables.
I fucking love Uncrustables and puppy chow.
I don't eat dog food, just full stop.
It's also known as White Trash, Crack and Muddy Buddies.
It's plain checks, mixed toasts, and peanut butter and chocolate,
then covered in powdered sugar.
I have that really rarely though, because you know,
I gotta keep up this nice figure.
So from my hobbies, when I'm not in the dungeon,
and I mean managing the Wonderland Hotel,
you can catch me reading a book,
practicing my knots and gardening to name a few.
As you can see, I do jiu-jitsu.
One time during a jiu-jitsu class,
I accidentally put a pair to sleep with just my thighs,
and in a like triangle, whoopsies.
I love to read fantasy novels.
Any form of escapism from the bland monotony of life
is enjoyable, but I do, you know,
read the occasional smutty novel or two.
Okay, I'll have fun to the next slide.
I really enjoy horror elements in shows,
or shows that make you think,
but I do also like, you know, trashy entertainment.
Like Love Island, I got a text.
I do watch a lot of anime,
but I'm probably kind of labeled like a normie for my taste.
I recently watched Dungeon Mashi and Freerun, you know,
also Me and All the Girlies have similar tastes.
If the theme is really sci-fi or fantasy,
I like it.
If it's, yeah, you know, like Firefly, Stargate, Star Wars,
all of it, I'm a freaking nerd.
Don't tell anybody though, I have to keep up, you know,
an air of mystery.
Some games you'll see me play will be like meta-ish games.
I love Inscription.
I like Souls Likes, like Elden Ring, I like Liza P.
I really want to dive into more retro games,
and also like RPG story-driven games like Elder Scrolls,
horror games like Alien and Amnesia,
and I recently discovered I like Roguelikes' Cult of the Lamb.
I'm embarrassed to admit this.
I played a lot of FPS growing up like Counter-Strike 2,
so I'm trying to widen my horizons.
Let's just not talk about my 600 plus hours.
Hehehe.
Let's move to my dislikes.
Okay, these are kind of self-explanatory.
Don't play your music too loud.
Nobody else wants to hear it.
I don't like being in really large crowds.
It just freaks me out post Miss Rona.
I don't like when somebody disobeys me.
Do not disobey me.
You will not like the consequences.
You may think it feels good. It won't.
Hehehe.
I don't like when people correct me.
I'm the one giving correction.
Alright.
And I hate getting interrupted during any sort of playtime,
and I hate when people put things in the wrong place.
If it's there, I like organize chaos.
Don't freaking do it.
Okay.
Alright, let me bring my body back real quick like
so you can see this beautiful face.
I bet you missed it, didn't you?
Sniff.
You guys smell, by the way.
I hope you knew that.
Oh!
I'm so far away.
Let me get a little closer to you.
Why am I so freaking huge?
Hehehe.
Okay.
I'm just going to be in the corner like this.
So ironically enough, I'm allergic to rabbits.
Sorry.
I have INFP personality type.
I'm very introverted.
Surprisingly enough.
After getting into our car accident,
I jumped off a cliff.
You'll learn more about that in the explanation as to why my 2.0.
I have three kitty cats.
You might have heard them in the background because they're going crazy.
My little girl, big mama,
and my big man.
And I've met the voice of Mario.
He was super freaking sweet.
Sniff.
We got to say let's go!
Okay.
So here are some of my goals.
I like to be a soul's like on stream.
I'd be an Elden Ring already,
and I'd be in Lies of P off stream,
but you know, I would like to do something with you.
I would like to learn another language,
because everybody else is super cool,
and I'm not, and they all know other languages,
so give me a suggestion.
I want to have a video hit 100k views,
and hit 10k subs,
because if I reach those milestones,
I know I'm doing something right,
and that you guys are enjoying my content.
So you know, I hope that you enjoy what I put out.
I want to go to a convention,
because it's not like they're doing it off-key right now,
and be like, hey,
and just try to like hit people with it.
I think that'd be really fun to hit people
with iPad self.
I would love to release another cover.
You guys will see that we have covers coming up.
Mine's not good, but you know,
we can try again.
I would love to voice in an anime
or some other form of animation.
I would love to travel
off-clad with the girlies,
and I want to make amazing friends
and you know,
there's a lot of amazing talents out there
that I would love to get to know.
Mm-hmm.
Here are some of my tags.
So here's my general art tag.
It's a sheebie art.
I'm not going too crazy with it.
My alternative, my naughty art tag
is a bondage.
Memes are a bun wild.
My live is sheebie live.
Clips are a cotton bomb clips,
and my fan name,
I came up with harem
this morning.
But also someone said like harlets,
hairlets, I don't know.
My sheebie bros, whatever.
We'll figure it out. My Yoshi marks are a rope and a bunny.
It's pretty self-explanatory.
Okay, so my first impressions
of the girls, I put like where I would take them
on a date.
So for Stronny, she's hardworking,
and I know she loves Lord of the Rings.
All of the Lord of the Rings movies together
while we snuggle.
And you know, just get really under those
cars.
Mercy, I would take her to a steak house
cause knives.
I think she, you know, I'll swipe a knife for her
five finger discount.
She's dangerous, she lives life on the edge.
Get it?
Anyways,
Azura, I want to cook a meal together with her
and take her on a picnic.
Probably something milk based.
I wouldn't buy that.
So, yeah.
Getting ice cream
with icy would be amazing.
If we could just watch the sunset.
You know, all the Aurora Borealis
if we go back to her hometown.
And just, you know,
suck on some popsicles together.
Some icicles.
Iced icicles.
Wow, the mom jokes are out today.
For Amy, I want to take her to a coffee shop
with a book star and feeder pastry.
She's so cute.
I just want to stuff her little face with food
and then find her more grimoire so she can, you know,
get her bro back.
I don't really know what they got going on,
but it's something.
Okay.
I want to give a huge thank you
to Squishy Ghoul
and Nari.
They did such an amazing job.
If they hadn't done all the work that they did,
I would not be here. None of the girls would be here.
So thank you so much.
Thank you to all these other wonderful people
who, without
their help,
I wouldn't have all this cool stuff.
Like, thank you. You guys worked so freaking hard.
I appreciate it so much.
Okay.
Let's go to my bedroom.
I can shut myself off.
Oh, yeah.
Okay. I'm like in a corner. Hold on.
Hello.
Hi.
You can see my beautiful face.
I'll go through. Hold on.
Let me just...
So you got my beautiful feet.
My little stompers.
My little stompers. I'm going to step on you with them.
You want a sniff? Too bad.
You're not good enough.
My lovely ankles.
My long, luscious legs
covered with my beautiful
tights.
And then, you know,
naturally, I'm wearing shabar
roads, but don't get it. Don't get it twisted
just because I'm tied up doesn't mean
I'm not going to be the one calling the shots.
Okay, sweetheart.
All right. That's what I thought.
Ew.
I don't like a short skirt,
you know.
You got to air out the girls. You know what I'm saying?
Somebody asked,
does these ropes leave marks? Yes.
I got my little office wear. You love my,
you know, succulent mole.
I like to wear a really
lacy lingerie.
I mean, this is just a shirt.
It's just a normal shirt. I don't know what you're talking about.
And then my lovely choker.
It's very avant-garde, don't you think?
And then we have
my beautiful face. I'm going to quickly run through
my toggles. We got
blushing. We got
sweating and blushing. We got
hard eyes sweating and blushing.
Then
I'm going to be really, really dark
if you disappoint me.
You disgust me.
I'll be really upset.
Why the fuck did you do that piece of shit?
And then I can cry, which is rare.
So I'm not going to use that for long.
And then
I can have a
real mouth.
And then I can be like
holy crap.
When were you going to tell me your dick was so small?
I'm sorry.
And then I can question my life
choices.
Okay, let me back up
a little bit.
Okay.
We got
some more. I have a leash.
Yeah.
You're on my leash, baby boy.
You better fucking
beg.
We
get closer with that.
And then
I can also bop you.
So be good.
You're not going to like where this goes.
Well, this is awkward.
Yeah, well, those are my toggles.
Okay, let me show my schedule real quick.
Oh my god, hi.
So we got the 2.0 tomorrow.
We got another craps treasure. I was going to do Bloodborne
because I was hoping they would have ported it for the PC,
but they didn't because they suck.
I love you, Sony.
We're going to do some drunk ASMR,
a little drunk ASMR role play.
I'm a rabbit, so of course we're going to do
Mr. Hopps Playhouse.
And then I'm going to play some Class of 09.
A Stanley Parable because fuck, office life.
Call to the Lamb and then
Vampire the Masquerade Bloodline.
So I hope
you will enjoy.
Wait a second.
Oh, is that
Is it that time?
Is it
that time?
At long last
the time for edge in is over.
Release
Reflicks and feast your eyes
on the lovely
Scottish cuttlefish
Strummy.
Give her all my love.
Thank you.